game of bones is one of the lesser known
and less understood installments in the
game of Thrones series more than mere
pornography game of bones might actually
reveal some deep secrets about the world
of Ice and Fire
game of bones begins with Varys and
Tyrion immediately breaking the fourth
wall they're making upon parody milord a
Guha Thrones yes and they're calling it
a game of balance the characters in Game
of Thrones have never before exhibited
this kind of self-awareness of their
place within a fictional story if they
know this what else might they reveal
one of the great enduring mysteries in
the game of thrones show is how Podrick
is able to so impress the prostitutes
maury Jenna and Kayla that they refuse
payment after a session in
Littlefinger's brothel in the first
episode of Game of Bones we witness
Podrick Payne's prowess firsthand but we
also get a glimpse of something even
more significant the identity of the
woman Podrick has sex with is unclear at
first she does have tattoos which might
suggest she's a volunteer slave of some
kind but one of the woman's tattoos
looks like a blue rose blue roses are
consistently associated with Lyanna
Stark the sister of Ned and mother of
John thought dead but apparently now
alive in disguise as a king's landing
prostitute this could have huge
implications for the story of Thrones
like how old Jon Snow react when he
finds that his mother is not only alive
but his fellating Podrick Payne these
are the kinds of big questions raised by
a game of bones in episode 3 of Bones
Daenerys Targaryen meets with Jorah and
Daario Daario looks like his season 3
self and Jorah doesn't look much like
Jorah at all but importantly we get a
glimpse of two of Danny's dragons who
strangely look suspiciously like cats
could there be some connection between
danny's three dragons and Tommen's three
kittens so pounce Lady whiskers and
we do know from a previous video that
there is a wealth of evidence connecting
sir pounds to the prophecy of azor Ahai
the hero prophesied to save the world
and to wake dragons from stone so it's
hard to draw firm conclusions here but
clearly the fate of Westeros is deeply
intertwined with that of Danny's dragons
and of Tommen's kittens in Episode four
of game of bones Jon Snow and Ygritte
encounter a white Walker who they call
apatite Walker but the Walker is seen
holding a white dildo as it happens a
white dildo also appears in book five of
Game of Thrones when Jon Snow lets
wildlings through the wall he
confiscates their treasures including an
ivory phallus how did a white Walker get
this artifact if it's held at Castle
black
have the others infiltrated the Nights
Watch his dolorous EDD secretly a white
Walker the evidence suggests probably
finally in episode 5 of game of bones we
see that King Joffrey has mysteriously
become a woman and there is a possible
textual explanation for this in book 4
maester aemon says that dragons are
neither male nor female but now one and
now the other as changeable as Flame
Dragons changed their sex just as
Joffrey has so the only logical
conclusion here is that Joffrey
Baratheon is literally a fire-breathing
dragon so in just five episodes game of
bones has shown us greater revelations
that we've seen in the last five years
of Game of Thrones books Lyanna stark is
alive dragons are cats the White Walkers
are stealing dildos from the Nights
Watch and Joffrey was a dragon all along
there is clearly a lot to be learned
from the porn parody game of bones if
you'd like to do your own analysis you
can watch bones for free at wood rocket
comm and that was not paid promotion god
save us all if there's a good chance
YouTube will D monetize this video
because violence and war is okay but
naked bodies and sex are offensive so if
you enjoyed this dumb video consider
supporting alt shift X on patreon
we got some great character and theory
analysis videos coming soon thank you to
patrons delft null HB anonymous and
squiggly one Cheers
you